hello and welcome to the new review your
source for everything anime and manga
and more specifically welcome to hunt
hunter 101 the series that breaks down
everyone and everything in the hunt
hunter world and today we are going to
be examining the most prolific
organization within the entire series as
well as its namesake
being the hunter association the hunter
association is a global third party
organization designed to cultivate
world-class talent in almost every area
imaginable and focus it towards solving
various problems achieving certain goals
or in some cases even mobilizing
offensive and defensive operations
on behalf of very very wealthy clients
the association itself is located in
swadani city although it has never been
confirmed exactly where in the world
this is in fact i can't even give you so
much as a continent it's just another
one of those miscellaneous metropolises
but as such a hunter generally has the
choice to either take jobs issued to the
association by the aforementioned
wealthy clients or simply use their
status within the association to pursue
their own personal objectives
so for example if you were a hunter then
your personal objective would be to
subscribe to the new
review for regular hunt under content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
which i think we both know would be
pretty damn awesome
but before we go too much further i
actually think it is important to
briefly dwell on the question of what
exactly is a hunter and i have made a
whole video regarding this so please do
feel free to watch that but despite
their prominence in the series this
profession is rarely explored primarily
because we see most of the series
through the eyes of gon and killua
neither of which particularly pursue the
profession of hunter despite being
licensed to do so i mean i guess you
could make the argument that they are
hunting jing but that is beside the
point hunter is actually quite a broad
and vague term in this world and it can
encompass effectively any top tier
profession that one can think of
so of course we have basic forms of
hunting such as treasure hunting or wild
game hunting the wild game in this world
sometimes being extraordinarily magical
beasts but what it means to be a hunter
is almost
entirely up to the individual in
question so to illustrate a classic
definition would be someone like bisky
who is a treasure hunter but expanding a
bit further we can also look at
mizeistom who is a crime hunter and that
basically means that he is a glorified
global detective but what a hunter is
can also delve into the abstract when we
encounter individuals like say cutie
beauty who is referred to as a cute
hunter and whose purpose is to solely
maintain the beauty of others
and this can be applied to quite
literally any profession so for example
if i were to
somehow pass the hunter exam then i
would probably label myself as a youtube
hunter which basically would mean that i
pursue this platform
only with all of the resources of the
hunter association available to me which
you know that would be nice and as such
there is an incredibly huge breadth of
different types of hunters so many so
that that's the reason why i made a
whole video on them but it is important
to understand that as far as the
association goes this
is essentially an organization of
world-class professionals who
in an ideal world come together to
mutually assist the goals of one another
although the large majority of hunters
do still operate alone
and as such it is actually entirely
possible and common for hunters to
become licensed and then just completely
ignore the actual association however
despite this grand freedom there are
still a collective of strict rules that
all hunters must obey
decreed by the association which are
known as the hunter bylaws and these
bylaws are a set of 10 rules almost a
form of 10 commandments and very much
acts as the glue that prevents the
association from descending into pure
anarchy and the first by-law is simply
that
hunters must always be on the hunt for
something which i imagine is implemented
to stop hunters from passing the exam
acquiring large amounts of wealth and
just retiring with no further impact on
the world although to be perfectly
honest i really don't see how this
particular bylaw would be strictly
enforced especially when the definition
of a hunter is just so
vague i mean even in my aforementioned
example of retirement i could just claim
to be a leisure hunter or something
constantly in pursuit of the greatest
pleasures that life has to offer with
minimal effort required and i really
don't see the association questioning
that
the next bylaw is a bit more restrictive
though being that hunters must have a
minimal understanding of martial arts
this includes learning nen which makes
sense because nen in the hunt hunter
world is a global standard of talent
even if an end user is unaware that they
are invoking it like komagi for example
next up once a hunter is licensed that
license cannot be revoked for any reason
and on the flip side a license will not
be reissued for any reason and the only
reason why i would come to question this
has to do with the next bylaw which is
that hunters shall not target other
hunters
unless they commit heinous crimes so
basically a hunter that commits crimes
won't have their licence revoked however
it will make them free game to any other
hunter
who so desired to track them down and i
imagine that a good example of someone
like this would be say ilmizoldic who is
a licensed hunter who has caused
incredible amounts of civilian
casualties during the chairman election
arc or actually an even better example
would be shalnok from the phantom troupe
who is both a hunter and has a class a
bounty and those really are the most
necessary rules to be aware of and the
next six pretty much just dive balls
deep into administration but we'll go
through them nonetheless because it does
greatly impact our understanding of the
association as a whole so next rule one
star
is given to a hunter who produces
remarkable achievements in a particular
field
two stars are given to a hunter who
fulfills the five articles which is
basically referring to the five previous
rules that we've explored holds an
official position
and has mentored a junior hunter who is
awarded a star three stars given to a
hunter who fulfills the six articles aka
the six prior rules we've explored and
produces remarkable achievements in
multiple fields the chief executive of
the hunter association must earn the
confidence of a majority of his
colleagues
when the position of chairman is vacated
the vote to elect the next chairman must
be conducted at once and deputy power is
given to the vice chairman in the
meantime the authority to decide on a
method to select new members is given to
the chairman however to significantly
change existing methods
requires the confidence of a majority of
colleagues which i suppose means holding
a referendum which all members of the
association can participate in
and finally any matter not mentioned
here will be decided in a cabinet
consisting of the chairman vice chairman
and staff advisors the chairman has the
authority to select vice chairman and
staff
and all right cool that's a lot like a
lot of rules there many of which are
only relevant to one particular arc in
the series but they are very important
as we now move on to examine the
hierarchy of the association
and at the very pinnacle we have the
chairman who for most of the series was
isaac netaro the chairman possesses
overwhelming power and influence within
the organization with no effective
checks or balances onset influence and
the direction in which they wish to take
the organization so obviously as you can
tell from that the decision to elect a
chairman is absolutely paramount because
if the wrong person were to be installed
then it could have incredible
ramifications on not just the
association but actually the entirety of
the human world and just on that i would
very much argue that much of the way we
see the hunt hunter world can be
attributed directly to chairman netro
whose leadership was highly focused on
fostering the strong whilst ignoring the
weak a trend that you can see almost
everywhere in the series but thus far
hunthunter has known three association
chairmans one of which was obviously
netaro who was the 12th chairman but
also paristan hill was the chairman for
all of like
two seconds and most currently we have
14th german cheetah yorkshire in charge
and within the association there is also
a vice chairman position an individual
who is granted almost as much control as
the chairman themselves however they
mainly exist to serve as backup in the
event that the chairman becomes
incapacitated or the position otherwise
deemed vacant in that case the vice
chairman serves as an interim however
they are not instantly promoted and an
election must take place within the
association
to decide who will permanently fill the
position however in regards to the vice
chairman no
election is necessary and that position
is filled entirely at the discretion of
the chairman and in the series paris and
hill would be the most famous vice
chairman although cheetah was also vice
chairman during pariston's two-second
chairmanship venture but very
interestingly it's currently unknown if
the association actually has a vice
chairman which is kind of odd to think
about because plenty of time has passed
and cheatle seems like a fairly strict
administrative law and order type but
there you go in addition to these roles
of leadership though there does also
exist an extended pool of staff advisors
who were assembled by the foreman
chairman netro and known as the zodiacs
this group comprises 12 individuals who
have had their skills recognized by the
chairman and are employed to act as
direct counselors as well as in the case
of netero
sparring partners with that said this
group is fairly disorganized due to
netro is an eclectic taste in
individuals and they don't function very
well as a cohesive unit having split
into various subfactions between them
however the zodiacs do contain some of
the most renowned and powerful hunters
in the world and now i would also be
quite remiss not to mention
beans a fascinating existence whose
humanity has neither been confirmed nor
denied however he does act as the
chairman's personal secretary and has
now i suppose technically served under
at least three different chairmen but
beans is probably the epitome of loyalty
within the hunter association and has
always
acted with the best interests of the
organization in mind something that i'm
not sure we can say about
literally any other character now
stepping further down into the
day-to-day running of the association
there have been
four widely identified branches of
operations that exist within this
extensive organization the most
prominent of which would be the exam
commission a task force entrusted with
the management of the annual hunter exam
and this includes structuring the format
of the exam as well as nominating
examiners both of which do change quite
radically from one year to the next the
examiners must
of course all be hunters and very
notably they are not paid for their role
as examiners although to be fair money
is really no object qualified hunters in
fact of the top 100 richest people in
the hunt hunter world
60 of them are hunters but in addition
to this there are also an incredible
suit of associates to the exam committee
many of whom are designated with the
role of pre-examiners who are charged
with weeding out those who are
completely unfit to even take the hunter
exam
and examples of individuals like this
would be the very vaguely named
captain or the quiz lady the one
constant with the exam committee though
is that the chairman of the association
also acts as the head of the exam
commission now next up we have the
review board which is a fairly
mysterious group actually who manage
assignments and delegate client requests
to hunters within the association
however what's really fascinating about
the review board is that they seem to
exist on a higher plane of power than
even that of the chairman as netra has
stated that even he was unable to deny
their decision once made so they seem to
represent an entirely new plane of power
altogether but rather sadly we are
currently unaware of even a single
character
who comprises a member of this board
moving on though from time to time a
temporary operation cohort is formed
known as the election task force which
is only really relevant when it comes
time to fill the chairman position which
doesn't happen often and of course its
purpose is to ensure the smooth running
of democracy within the association
as well as defining the structure of the
election itself and leadership of this
council in the series was actually given
to beans with the zodiac members also
acting as advisors and implementers and
finally we have the disciplinary
committee a group whose purpose has not
been solidly defined but one could make
the assumption that they exist to ensure
order within the association
although as i've said before exactly how
this is possible is kind of unknown
mainly due to the large degree of
freedom and immunity that hunters are
granted in general but we do have at
least one example of a member of the
disciplinary committee who would be a
man by the name of bushido ambitious
although rather unfortunately he was
probably murdered by hisoka during the
chairman election arc but apart from
that the only formal hierarchy that
still remains to be explored is the star
system which we briefly covered in the
hunter bylaws which does go on to state
their requirements however for
particularly accomplished hunters they
are awarded with a star rating from one
to three with three obviously being the
highest and in fact in the series we
currently only know of three characters
who have achieved this being cheadle
harriston and another zodiac member
being bought by gigante so in essence
this organization is still quite the
mysterious entity
despite the focus given to it in the
series during the latter arcs it still
raises a lot of questions in terms of
how the association is funded given that
they are a completely independent
organization like for example do various
countries of the world perhaps the v6
each pay into it in exchange for having
access to specialty hunters or is this a
completely privately funded endeavor who
knows maybe it even operates as a
phantom nation and it taxes its hunters
but i kind of doubt that in any case it
mainly forms a background feature of the
series anyway a rough framework to set
against the adventures of our main
protagonists although the association
itself is quite fascinating and i do
hope that we continue to learn more
about it in the future
but what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more hunt on
content then please do feel free to
check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for
regular hunt on glory delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time